la vie n'est pas un jeu ou du moins
c'est ce qu'on m'a fait croire pendant
un petit moment
depuis que j'étais jeune en fait on me
dit tout le temps la vie n'est pas un
jeu quand j'étais à l'école au lycée à
l'université
eh ben c'est comme ça tout doit être un
petit peu sérieux mais est un fan de
jeux vidéo et avec une bonne fibre
entrepreneuriale
au fait j'ai créé avec des amis un 10
ans quand même la coupe de tunisie des
jeux vidéo est une idée games qui se
veut être une plateforme
au fait on voulait leur offrir une sorte
de l'espace dans lequel ils peuvent
s'amuser un espace pour des jeunes comme
nous à qui on a dit la vie n'est pas un
jeu mais en fait aussi c'est un espace
si j'ose dire aussi un écosystème dans
lequel ils peuvent faire exploser leur
talent
et oui je parle bien de talent parce
qu'aujourd'hui le jeu vidéo 20 il ya des
professionnels des joueurs
professionnels qui jouent à des jeux qui
sont comme counter strike fifa league of
legends n'est pas par exemple on a des
équipes de counter strike qui sont
sponsorisés qui sont payés pour venir
jouer à des tournois on a des ligues de
professionnels sur fifa la dernière
coupe du monde par rapport à league of
legends a créé les premiers gamer
millionnaire parce que l'équipe a gagné
5 millions de dollars alors certes ces
gens là ces jeux là sont faits pour du
hardcore gaming donc la cible c'est des
jeunes mâles avec un profil de 18 ans
mais au fait avec l'avènement des
réseaux sociaux de tout ce qui est
mobile facebook les tablettes etc
même la wii est bien la donne a changé
parce qu'aujourd'hui certaines études
vont elles estiment que puisque la
moitié de la planète jouent aux jeux
vidéo est un fait super marquant c'est
que ben il ya beaucoup de femmes qui
jouent c'est presque la moitié des
femmes qui jouent avec une moyenne d'âge
de 35 ans et je vois plusieurs d'entre
vous veulent à sourire parce que vous
êtes en train de penser à toutes les
notifications que vous recevez sur
facebook
s'il vous plaît donnez moi des jetons
s'il vous plaît donnez moi des bonbons
peut-être même des vaches
alors ben au fait ces jeux là je vous
comprend un cd jeux qui sont très
addictif qui sont très engageant on
dirait limite qu'il ya de la magie
derrière et personnellement je pense que
les créateurs du jeu vidéo c'est des
magiciens parce que de par son âge
choses essentielles la magie elle est
définie par ben par beaucoup d'habileté
et c'est ce que font on utilise nos
mains pour créer des jeux
il ya beaucoup de science et de
technologie
est ce le fondement même du jeu vidéo il
ya beaucoup de psychologie pour l'aspect
addictif et engageant mais aussi
beaucoup de mises en scène pour créer le
monde dans lequel on est et donc ces
magiciens des temps modernes d'un cd
créatif c'est des créateurs c'est des
game designers à la base mais aussi des
artistes qui font de la 2d notre des ya
des musiciens et qu'est ce que serait
pas un bon je sens une bonne musique et
bien sûr et des développeurs alors ces
magiciens dans leur grand art dans leur
grand talent un certain moment ils sont
10 et ils ont vu l'impact qu'avait les
jeux vidéo sur les joueurs leurs
engagements et sont dit pourquoi ne pas
prendre les techniques de jeu et les
appliquer sur tout sur la vie et à
partir de ce moment là bas il ya un
terme qui a vu le jour et c'est là
gainey fication alors la gamification
maintenant c'est un terme qui est en
train de beaucoup pesé parce que il ya
de la technologie derrière etc
mais ça existe depuis un bon petit
moment et donc j'ai pour vous
aujourd'hui ici une énigme et j'aimerais
bien à laquelle vous répondiez qu'est-ce
qui pourrait dans le contexte de la
gamification faire relier un avion une
cuillère et un garage
j'ai un autre indice toujours pas alors
qu'ils se rappellent du jeune talent
femmes au canada
c'est un exemple pur de game ification
parce qu'on a une problématique on a un
enfant qui ne veut pas manger parce que
ce n'est pas bon le bois l'eau douce est
pas bon d'un autre côté on a une mère
qui est un objectif
c'est faire manger à son fils quelque
chose d'essentiel pour qu'ils puissent
grandir et bien se développer et 20 en
as mis du fun en ami d'une technique de
jeu avec du score à ya pas de cave à 14
ou sera détruit et on le fait évoluer et
d'ailleurs pour les intéressés ben et
des industriels qui ont vraiment créé la
morale sa taille à l'heure vous pouvez
rester pouvaient la trouver un petit peu
partout alors fondamentalement la
gamification et ben c'est sortir d'une
situation qui est un petit peu ennuyeuse
ou qui pillent et peut-être en manque de
productivité pour rajouter dessus une
couche donc de jeu de mécanique de jeu
qu'on sait utiliser pour atteindre un
objectif
alors cet objectif peut être business
professionnelles sociales personnelles
peut-être et donc pour ça pour créer
donc tout un concept pour rendre la
chose un petit peu plus facile
alors j'ai plein d'exemples aujourd'hui
à vous proposer le premier bain c'est
volkswagen qui sait ni quand même sur ça
depuis un petit moment ils ont créé un
site web qui s'appelle de fun feoli
points comme et donc ça c'est cet
exemple est vraiment génial parce qu'ils
sont rendu compte qu'à la sortie du
métro
et bien tout le monde prenait
l'escalator alors que l'escalier qu'on
pouvait le voir il n'est pas très grand
donc ils ont pris les marches des
escaliers et les ont rendus en touches
de piano
donc quand vous marchez sur les sur les
marches et ça fait sortir des notes de
piano et ceux rendus compte qu apple en
deux heures il y avait plus de 66
pourtant des gens qui avaient switcher
vers le vert les escaliers à notre
exemple et qui n'est pas des moindres
ça s'appelle foldit et c'est un site au
fait c'est une simulation qui a été créé
par l'université de washington
au fait c'est un peu c'est un puzzle
autour de quelque chose de très sérieux
qui est de la science et qui et comment
extraire ou plutôt comment décortiquer
une protéine qui est la molécule la plus
complexe qui existe et donc ils ont
sorti cette simulation en ligne
ils ont eu la surprise d'avoir deux cent
quarante mille joueurs inscrits dès les
premières semaines est un fait encore
plus incroyable c'est que toute cette
communauté à la réussi à résoudre un
problème en dix jours ce que des
scientifiques n'ont pas pu faire en 15
ans et ça c'est par rapport à l'enzyme
mp 1 v qui est relié au virus du sida et
donc ça a fait un bon scientifique par
rapport à la recherche contre le sida
le troisième exemple que j'ai eh ben
c'est nike +
c'est une application au fait que vous
avez dans votre téléphone donc quand
vous mettez à courir çà fait du tracking
de votre activité vous pouvez voir votre
évolution
vous pouvez être en compétition avec
d'autres utilisateurs tête et vos amis
facebook qui sont sur l'application est
bien sûr ça peut vous offrir des badges
alors qu'on voue corps et trois fois par
semaine ça vous donne des trophées etc
alors moi personnellement je suis
utilisateurs de cette application là et
pour vous raconter une petite histoire
personnelle bien au fait il ya un an et
demi j'étais un petit peu grassouillet
je faisais 98 kg et pourtant j'étais
sportif et mais bon voilà vu que j'étais
j'avais un rythme de vie qui était un
petit peu vous savez entrepreneurs et
tour n'a pas le temps on n'a pas le
temps on n'a pas le temps donc voila et
mes amis me disent aimer va courir aux
éditions de recourir c'est pour moi
c'est l'activité qui est la plus
embêtante mais là plus courir corps et
oui et tu peux le faire le matin le soir
même quand tu es en voyage et ou alors
on m'a recommandé d'installer
l'application nike+ je suis dit allez je
vais laisser vu que je suis geek
automatiquement je cours avec mon
téléphone et tout ça peut le faire et
donc j'ai installé nike+ et ben je peux
vous dire qu'un an après cette
application fait courir 210 km moi qui
n'aime pas courir j'ai gagné 17 trophées
virtuel et j'ai réussi à faire un semi
marathon et l'objectif donc voulu voir à
la photo et c'est par hasard avec rennes
salvifique est une très bonne amie à moi
voilà c'est des photos cd avec son
cercle de feu doux qui nous dit mais
regarde la différence
ah oui c'est flagrant alors qu'est-ce
qui a fait que je sois vraiment engager
vraiment a dicté par rapport à quelque
chose que je n'aime pas à la base courir
ces offres
eh ben au fait c'est une science et de
la mécanique c'est des méthodes de fait
la gamification est une des plus connues
d'entre elles s'appelle tout simplement
games et game ont fait ça ce se divise
en quatre parties alors j'ai pour gold
donc on met nos objectifs quels sont les
objectifs qu'on a envie d'atteindre on
met les actions les mécaniques de jeu
pour aider le joueur à atteindre ses
objectifs
bien entendu il faut du mérite il faut
lui donner durward bravo tu avais tu as
mangé
le brûlot bravo tu as couru bravo tu as
fait des choses et bien entendu un
projet de gamification se doit d'être
vivant il se doit de continuer dans la
ville donc automatiquement fait de
l'auto évaluation par rapport à votre
guise me fication et tout ceci nous
introduit un concept que moi j'adore
beaucoup c'est le principe de flou le
flou au fait c'est ce moment magique où
votre compétence est proportionnelle à
la à l'ardeur de la tâche que vous êtes
en train de faire et ça va en augmentant
c'est au fait vous êtes en frénésie vous
êtes un super héros à ce moment-là
mettre à mal comme on dit pas ce que
vous sentez vous pouvez tout faire
alors ce principe là il est génial mais
il assez il assez il est très sensible
parce que si la tâche aux fêtes et les
trop facile ça devient ennuyeux et si la
tâche et les trop difficile ça devient
frustrant et dans les deux cas on va
quitter donc il faut vraiment créé le
flou par rapport à toute expérience de
gainey fication alors aujourd'hui ici
pour le tedx avec notre équipe
ben on a essayé d'imaginer comme un
challenge qu'est ce qu'on pourrait
qualifier a donné en exemple ou
peut-être même à offrir directement
parce qu'on est comme ça on est des
citoyens il a envie de donner aussi
quand on nous donne et au fait on a
commencé à poser des questions autour de
nous on a posé des questions aux gens
qui nous entourent et on leur a dit
alors quelles sont les choses les plus
embêtante les choses que vous aimez pas
le plus les choses les plus quand vont
dire voilà et on a eu plein de réponses
et la réponse qui revenait souvent
c'était la relation avec
l'administration et les tâches
administratives et je pense que tout le
monde est d'accord
voilà et donc on a commencé aussi à
faire de la recherche derrière et on est
tombé sur cet article là que
certainement plusieurs d'entre vous ont
dû voir comme quoi l'administration
tunisienne n'était pas efficace comme
quoi ils travaillent que huit 8 minutes
par jour comme quoi y avait beaucoup
d'absentéisme et c est donc au fait on
n'est pas là pour tirer sur une
ambulance
il ya des problèmes d'administration un
petit peu partout donc aujourd'hui on
est ici vraiment dans un monde de
construction et de propositions donc on
a commencé à réfléchir à cela et il ya
une mise en situation
alors moi ou elite quand je veux quand
je vais dans une administration
quelconque est bien au fait
la première chose que je fais 20 dès que
j'arrive un jeu court très vite donc
récupérer mon ticket et je regarde le
prompteur et généralement je suis très
très loin dans la file d'attenté
je veux mais attendre à attendre
à attendre et ce moment-là ça m'énerve
parce que je suis en train de perdre mon
temps dans ton et précieux ça ne crée de
la frustration de l'énervement
je suis pas bien mais au moment magique
où mon numéro s'affiche jeu court direct
j'ai un regain d'énergie je me dis ok
c'est bon ça va se passer et je me
retrouve en face de monsieur grincheux
qui est derrière le guichet il est
énervé je suis énervé et donc
automatiquement l'expérience elle va pas
être bonnes c'est prévu comme ça alors
on s'est mis à étudier un petit peu
monsieur gage pour dire c'est à ce
niveau là qu'il faudrait peut-être agir
et donc au fait monsieur grincheux c'est
un humain comme nous tous il a une vie
mais par contre il est en manque
d'engagement ou de dévouement ou
peut-être de motivation par rapport à
son travail et donc on s'est mis à
réfléchir qu'est ce qui pourrait faire
en sorte que ce monsieur grincheux
devient monsieur cordiale tout en
n'utilisant et technique il va pas
coûter d'argent cette administration là
et bien les fameux tickets pourquoi ne
pas les utiliser comme étant des bons
points alors moi quand je vais devant
monsieur qui est derrière le guichet si
l'expérience se passe bien et bien le
ticket au lieu de jeter par terre je le
lui donne c'est un bon point pour lui et
donc la personne va se mettre à cumuler
accumulés a accumulé à accumuler les
tickets et mais en plus il est pas seul
dans cette administration
ils sont plusieurs et donc du coup on
pourrait mettre un système de classement
qui est le monsieur le plus cordial ou
la madame la plus cordiale et c'est
alors à ce niveau là leur manager et ben
déjà il va pouvoir voir qui est le plus
sympathique le plus cordial avec les
gens mais aussi c'est de l'excellent
festive pour parce qu'il ya des gens qui
se donnent vraiment par rapport à la
tâche qu'ils sont en train de faire mais
ce système a ses limites parce que
l'être humain va commencer à se mettre
des bâtons dans les roues vu qu'il ya un
classement
alors on a pensé un score d'equipe donc
le manager rien alors il dit ce mois-ci
on doit absolument récolter 2000 smileys
et toute l'équipe travaille ensemble
donc à chaque fois que quelqu'un ait un
smiley le gard pollue mais aussi les
comptabiliser dans les cordes équipe
tout ceci si une fois on a atteint
l'objectif par rapport aux scores
d'équipement valeur débloquer une sorte
de boutique virtuelle dans laquelle ils
vont pouvoir convertir leurs smiley ça
peut être en tickets restaurant ça peut
être en congés ça peut être même une
surprise avec le boss va savoir qu'est
ce que ça pourrait être
m
alors vu qu'on est dans un système
d'accumulation on ne peut pas régresser
ça ne peut que s'accumuler s'accumulent
et de toutes les manières ça va ramener
un plus psychologique à toute cette
équipe a toutes ces personnes alors nous
fondamentalement on pense que vraiment
grâce à un petit ticket monsieur
grincheux pourrait vraiment devenir
monsieur cordiale et améliorer cette
expérience qu'on a avec l'administration
alors la gamification au fait on peut
l'utiliser partout on peut vraiment
l'utiliser par rapport à notre vie
personnelle par rapport à notre vie
professionnelle par rapport à on la
retrouve dans le e-learning on la
retrouve dans la science on retrouve un
petit peu partout et en fait je vous
invite tous
c'est une science qui n'est pas
compliqué à faire des petites recherches
et c'est à vous traînez haut niveau au
niveau de votre couple peut-être au
niveau de votre relation avec la famille
avec vos amis et c'est d'essayer d'un
petit peu tous vinifiés ben ça deviendra
déjà un petit peu plus léger et ça
démontrera un petit peu à tous ceux qui
un jour nous ont dit que la vie n'est
pas un jeu et bien que c'est le meilleur
jeu qui puisse exister parce que on est
en train de vivre
merci beaucoup